- What's up guys, welcome to VidCon 2017.
This is the seventh
VidCon that I've been to.
I am kind of in shock that
I've been going to this many.
Last year, I wasn't able to make it though
because I went to Germany,
but we're back this year.
VidCon, oh my gosh, let's do it.
(upbeat music)
♪ I'm so in love with you. ♪
- Do you like the term influencer?
'Cause I don't think--
- It's kind of a bad term.
- I feel like it is,
but I don't know what else to call us.
I mean, they used to call us YouTubers,
- Or creators.
(upbeat music)
- Here we go.
So we're heading to my meet up now,
and this is how we roll.
Like literally, this is how we roll.
(upbeat music)
So you guys probably already know,
but Escape the Night has
just premiered today.
Woo.
Okay so, does anybody get buried alive?
Or is that just reserved for me only.
- You're the lucky one, it's just you.
But there are some pretty
crazy deaths that happen.
- I can't wait to see it.
Oh man, we watched the last season,
like I watched it with my whole family,
like we watched it on TV,
like it was a real, official experience.
It was so good.
- Yeah, well this season is,
we had a bigger budget.
- Woohoo, that means more people die.
- Yeah and in crazier ways.
Basically, this season,
there's like a new monster
every episode that we're dealing with.
- Oh, I love it.
And guess who else is here, Francesca.
- Oh hi.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm great, how are you?
- Good, I miss you.
I feel like I haven't seen you in--
- Joey took over.
- She's mine now.
- Yeah.
- Oh hi.
Hi Alex, hello.
- Hi, how are you guys, this is great.
- So I just started watching,
you've got some crazy like cartoons.
- I do.
- And all kinds of things.
- She's gonna voice one,
she's gonna be so good.
- Yes, please, please please, I love--
- We're gonna make her this
girl that gets buried alive.
It's gonna be phenomenal.
- I love being buried alive.
- I know, and it's gonna be animated,
so you don't have to get the dirt on you.
- I love doing VO because I can just sit
in my pajamas and be like a hot mess,
and I'm like, cool, this is me.
Nobody knows.
- She knows my secrets.
- It's great, you can also juggle,
like very, how long
have you been juggling?
- I used to be a professional
juggler for like 10 years.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- That's a long time, when did you start?
- When I was 15, I started juggling.
Now, it's animation all the time, 24/7.
- That's cool.
- And we're gonna cook something, right?
- Yeah, well, I wanna
learn to juggle knives.
So, how do I start?
- Can we make something
that has to be chopped?
That way, when we cook it,
we try and juggle chop it?
- Well, I'm thinking what we can do is,
we can go out in my backyard,
because I feel like we have
a little more room there,
so we can juggle, I can juggle items,
and then you can chop them.
- So we can barbecue,
do you have a barbecue?
- No, but I can get one on Amazon.
- Yeah yeah.
- This is so cool, okay great.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- I am wonderful, I missed
E3, but you know what?
It was so nice watching
you at E3 this year.
It made me feel like I was there.
- Well thank you.
- You did such a good job.
- Thank you.
When you said you weren't gonna be there,
I'm like, you're probably gonna be able
to make so much more
content not being there.
- That's what I did.
I literally cranked it out.
I really scripted my
Francis videos this year.
Couple of them went out pretty viral.
I was really happy about it.
- That's good.
- I missed seeing you,
and I missed playing games.
How was Battlefront?
- It was actually really fun.
I mean I liked the first one,
and I'm super excited about this one.
Because there's actually a story mode too.
And I can play as Rey.
- I can't wait, I really can't.
Like this years E3, everybody
else calls it a snoozer right?
'Cause there's like a lot of
the same games from last year
that we're waiting on,
but I'm still excited
about all these games.
I have two years worth
of excitement built in.
And we're finally gonna play Battlefront.
I missed Last of Us wasn't
anywhere, that sucked,
but otherwise amazing.
It's so good to see you.
- You too, I'm so glad you made
it out to VidCon this year.
- I'm so glad to be here.
You know, again, the
people that don't know,
we go way back to the Game Awards.
Three or four years ago
was our first time meeting.
- We hosted.
We actually presented together.
- Right, it was awesome.
- It was so fun.
- And, I fell in love with you.
- Aw, you're the best.
- You're my favorite.
- You're the best, well,
have a good VidCon.
- I absolutely will, you know.
You just made my VidCon right here.
- This is great, you made my VidCon.
I'm so glad you're here.
And I love your dog too, oh my gosh.
- Oh, but Maddy is so cute too.
- They need to meet.
- When are we getting a play date?
- It needs to happen.
I'll put Maddy on a plane,
we'll come out to visit.
- Oh, please.
- I said this the last time
when I saw you at Disney.
It still hasn't happened yet,
but it will happen.
- See, Sammy can't even get into a car.
He can't even,
like taking him to the
vet is an entire ordeal.
- He's gonna see Maddy and be like,
uh-uh, get out of here, this is my ground.
How are you girls?
- Oh my God, you're camera is amazing.
What is this?
- Hi, hi, hi.
This is kind of fluffy.
- This is my dog, Connolly.
- Really?
- She's so cute.
- Oh my gosh, how old?
- She's 12 weeks.
- Oh, you're so sweet.
You're gonna be a big boy.
Now to E3.
Now at VidCon.
- Yes, we keep running into each other.
- Hi, how are you?
- Hi.
- Last time I saw you was on a plane.
No, actually it wasn't.
- We got on the plane,
then we had a movie thing,
it's just like we're all over the place.
- The plane is very memorable to me.
- Pittsburgh, it's all connecting.
- Small world.
Happy VidCon.
- Happy VidCon.
- Hi.
What's up.
- Are you guys loving VidCon so far?
- Yeah, it's always crazy,
lots of fun craziness going on.
- Lots of craziness.
- You guys look so cute.
- Thank you.
- I found a fellow Tool fan.
Like this is, this is amazing.
Okay show us your patch.
I'm so excited.
How long have you been watching my videos?
- Since 2006.
- Oh my gosh.
- Half my life.
- Let's see it, okay there it is.
And then I signed, your matchbook.
- Is this your phone?
- Yes.
- Oh I thought it was, oh hi, hi guys.
I thought this was somebody else's phone.
- No, this is mine, I'm vlogging.
It's great.
This is great, yay!
I'll spin the camera.
Do you remember?
I think you were actually
in my first slow-mo video.
When the iPhone had slow-mo.
- Yeah, that was a great video.
- It was, yeah, I don't think
it was that good actually.
- It was medium.
- I don't remember what it was.
But it was something, it
was something, hi Freddy.
- I remember it, it was mediocre.
It was a mediocre video.
- Actually, yes you were, wait,
and then we went to the Apple store
trying to get you a phone.
- Yeah that's right, we
had a phone adventure.
- Yeah, these were all
things that happened.
And now here we are.
And there's Bernie.
Oh, I almost hit you.
- You almost clothes-lined the dude.
- I wish you guys could've
seen it. It was amazing.
This quality is really great.
Front facing camera, really good.
(hip hop music)
Hey guys, where we going today?
- San Bernardino.
It's so far away.
We're going to see Tool.
I saw them not too long ago in Pittsburgh,
and it was the best thing ever.
But we have an hour and 27
minutes to go to get there.
So we're basically gonna
get there just in time
to see them.
And then we have to
leave a little bit early
because there's 65,000
people at this venue.
That's a lot of people.
Here's the thing,
I think out of all four of us,
I mean, I guess, Ed, you're
like kind of a fan too, yeah?
Right?
- I'm a huge fan, yeah.
- Okay, well, that's news to me.
- That's what he like suddenly
said it the other day.
- What?
- And I go, now what a minute.
Why am I going?
- Jenna's not even a fan, and Francesca,
you can't even see her because
she's blocked over here.
- Oh, that's where I am.
- What is that?
- What's what?
- It's the screen.
- This.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I was like,
how am I in the chair,
but the chair is in front of me.
That's not the chair.
- Francesca's here.
- Francesca just woke up.
- I'm into Tool because Tool came out
when I was in high school.
- Yeah.
- Those were the days.
- I mean, we're listening
to them right now,
getting real pumped up.
- The 90's.
(rock music)
- I'm so excited.
I don't know, are we old?
Maybe.
I don't even know how to
listen to Tool if I want to.
Because they're not on streaming.
They're no where.
Like, you have to listen
to them on YouTube.
That's what we're doing.
- Get a cassette tape.
- Digital doesn't work.
- Digital, have you heard of it?
So we're on our way,
that's what we're doing.
I just wanted to say hello.
This is also a part of my VidCon vlog.
I filmed nothing at VidCon, at all.
I did so many things and
they were so back to back,
I was like oh crap, forgot to film.
So, that's that.
Maddy's not feeling well.
- Aw.
- Matt's watching him right now.
- He's gonna be good.
- He has an inflamed tummy.
I think it's because I
fed him so many treats
for his birthday.
- It's okay.
- It's my fault.
- It's because he eats actual
crap off of the street.
- He's a street dog.
Okay cool let's go to Tool.
(rock music)